does anyone in here work in the medical
profession by any chance
yeah what do you do
you're a what sorry
a ward sister well done
that's a great job i always wanted to
work in the medical profession i wanted
to be a doctor
or maybe if you'd worked harder
it is so cool to be back together with
these guys doing this you know
because this is a group where i know i
fit in you know
because the way the world is now you can
be part of a group and not even know
you're a part of a group until you read
about it or see it on tv and i'll give
you an example of what i'm talking about
my wife and i we love watching like uh
dateline 2020 those shows
but you know how every week they will
they will feature a disease
and i swear to you every week no matter
what the disease is my wife has it
there'll be three people on the planet
that have this disease my wife is one of
them
she just watches it going
i've got it
i have every one of those symptoms i'm
like you do not have testicular cancer
[Applause]
you don't even have testiculars
but they made us such a bunch of
paranoid nuts you know because when when
i was growing up there were two
medicines in the world you had aspirin
and camphofenik that that's all there
was
now there's so many medicines they got
this prescription stuff that they
advertise on tv and i swear half the
time the side effects are 50 times worse
than what the medicine cures
it's like try new flora floor for itchy
watery eyes it's flora floor side
effects may include nausea vomiting
water weight gain lower back pain
receding hairline eczema seborrhea
psoriasis itching taping clothing liver
spots blood clots ringworm excessive
body odor uneven tire wear pioreo
gonorrhea diarrhea halitosis scoliosis
loss of bladder control hammer toe the
shanks low sperm count warp floors
cluttered drawers hunchback heart attack
low resale value on your home
feline leukemia athlete's foot head lice
club foot msmd vd fleas anxiety
sleeplessness drowsiness poor gas
mileage
tooth decay parvo warts unibrow lazy eye
fruit flush chest pains clogged drains
hemorrhoids dry heaving and sexual
dysfunction
i'm watching it going you know what i'll
just have itchy watery eyes
my wife
went into a coma oh i'm sorry to hear
that
and uh
the doctor said to me
you won't hear this from any 1935 comet
he says to me
there's one way to wake her up but it's
a little unconventional
you go in there and you have oral sex
with her i said by god
he says i've seen it work i said well
i'm willing to try
so i go in there i'm in there about five
minutes and i come out
i said doc she's choking
[Applause]
like this is my regular speaking voice
but if i'm in a public bathroom and
someone knocks too suddenly on the stall
door i go into a whole different
speaking voice which is someone's in
here
someone's in here
so they're going to be like i think
there's a carnival barker in there
i think someone's trying to drum up
business for a carnival
i decided to do something about all this
anxiety recently i decided i was going
to try and get a xanax prescription i
don't know if anyone here has ever tried
xanax but it's fantastic
very muted claps for xanax
you don't really get woos it's more like
yeah
i didn't know how to get a xanax
prescription though drugs like that are
tricky sometimes but i talked to a
friend of mine and he said hey i did
this he said that he had a regular
doctor's appointment and at the end of
it he said to his doctor hey doctor
sometimes i get nervous on airplanes and
the doctor just wrote him a xanax
prescription and i was like yeah that's
the type of low bra i'm looking for
i'll take your advice friend i've never
listened to before
so i go to a clinic and i go in and i'm
just going to go in for you know a
regular type of checkup and at the end
i'll ask about xanax so i get to the
front desk and they have a why are you
here sheet and i want to pick something
that will get me in and out really
quickly and i look down and i see
frequent urination
and i was like perfect
that'll be a super quick visit you know
i'll just be like hey sometimes i pee a
lot and the doctor will be like me too
crazy right
and i'll be like i get nervous on
airplanes
so i checked off frequent urination and
i sat down in the waiting area and i
waited for three hours i finally go back
to the observation room and oh in the
observation room there is a male nurse
standing there and he has a batman
sticker on his stethoscope a batman
necklace and a batman watch he was kind
of moving around the whole time you know
he was just like all right i am too
blessed to be stressed let's do it what
are you allergic to besides work and
then he takes something and he throw it
over his shoulder and be like beats
working like all of his jokes were very
anti-work which is not always what you
want from a healthcare professional
the doctor comes in the room and the
doctor looks at my chart and he says oh
you're here for frequent urination how
many times a day are you urinating and i
tried to think of a number
that would warrant a doctor visit
so i said 11.
and that was too many times to say
the doctor looks at me says you're
peeing 11 times a day
then you may have something wrong with
your prostate so what we need to do
some of you are ahead of me
so i don't know exactly how he phrased
it
but the gist of it was hey
if this visit is to continue i'm going
to stick part of my hand up your ass
and i didn't know what to say
because i couldn't be like no that's
okay
i was lying
it was a lie
to get drugs
you know like a crime
so what i did was
i pulled down my pants and i walked over
to the observation table and i put my
hands down on the observation table like
this and by the way part of me was like
whatever you know
you know those days when you're like
this might as well happen
adult life is already so goddamn weird
so i'm bent over like this on the table
and the doctor comes up behind me goes
no no not on your hands on your elbows
and he knocks me down like that
and this is so much worse
than this i don't know why i think it's
that this has like a little remaining
dignity to it you know what i mean this
is sort of like oh stick it in i am an
american
this is like you're leaning over the
edge of a cruise ship and you're like ah
we are approaching martinique
he knocked me down to my elbows
and then
he stuck his hand in
and you know how sometimes you're like i
bet i know what most things feel like
you know
you just think you'll know
i did not know
what this was gonna feel like
and this was the actual sound i made i
went oh
but i didn't say it
like it came from my vocal cords but it
was totally involuntary
it was as if a ghost had been trapped in
my belly
and finally flew out towards the light
[Applause]
and then
when he pulled his hand out
we've gotten to know each other pretty
well
so i will phrase this as delicately as i
can
i did not realize that when the doctor
pulls his hand out it feels like
because the only thing that's ever come
out of your butt before has been
so
he pulls his hand out and i thought that
i was
into his hand
so i yelled i'm sorry
[Applause]
this is a very routine procedure by the
way for most doctors and so far he's had
to deal with oh
and i'm sorry
and he didn't even let me off the hook
you know he wasn't like ah don't worry
you didn't into my hand
he just threw his glove away and was
like
and i was about to ask about xanax but
then he said all right your prostate's
fine but we still need to do a blood
test so i pulled up my pants and
shuffled away
feeling different
and he yells out into the hall he goes
hey we're doing a blood test get in here
and batman dances back in and he's like
all right we're going to do a blood test
you look different let's do it
the doctor left the room so i'm alone
with batman i just need this blood test
to be over okay but first i had to tell
batman something i said batman look i'm
one of those people who when you take
blood from me sometimes i can faint and
i was in the waiting area for three
hours and i haven't eaten all day and
i'm really worried i'm gonna faint
and batman said to me and i'll never
forget it
you're not gonna faint so
i stick my arm out batman puts the
needle in i immediately collapse on the
ground
i wake up and i am covered in sweat
lying on the observation table i wake up
i open my eyes and i see batman's face
he's looking at me and he goes you gotta
go
and i said can i please
talk to the doctors though first
because
sometimes
i get nervous
on airplanes
and batman said the doctor's gone
so i got my stuff
and i left
the moral of the story is
that if you've been nervous your entire
life you should ask your doctor about
xanax because if you lie to him he will
stick his finger
in your ass
and if you do suffer from frequent
urination keep it to yourself
i went to that clinic two years later
for a different checkup and as i was
leaving who did i run into but batman
and he smiled at me and he was wearing
reading glasses to show that time had
passed
[Music]
that little bit of arrogance in the
medical community i think we could all
live without
like when you go to see the doctor you
don't see the actual doctor first you
must wait in the waiting room there's no
chance of not waiting that's the name of
the room
the doctors are all back though we can't
take them now we've already got this
room
and you sit there you pretend you're
reading your little magazine you're
actually looking at the other people
i wonder what he's got
that guy's a goner
then they call you get very excited when
they call you
because you think now you're going to
see the doctor
but you're not
now you're going into the next smaller
waiting room
now you don't even have your magazine
now you got your pants around your
ankles you're sitting on that butcher
paper they pull out over the table
sometimes i bring a pickle with me and i
put it next to me right there on the
table
i don't know
in case the doctor wants to fold the
whole thing up for it to go order
get your pants off and get in there and
i will tell you what i think doctors
always want your pants off take your
pants off
doctor would like to see you with no
pants
just get them off it's my head i said
take your pants off
but i hate the extra weight so i start
maybe i'll start screwing around with
some of his stuff you know maybe i'll
turn that thing up a little bit
whatever the hell that does
take all the tongue depressors out lick
them all put them all back
[Applause]
yeah two can play at this waiting game
just once i'd like to say to the doctor
you know what i'm not ready for you yet
why don't you go back in your little
office i'll be in a minute and get your
pants off
then we'll see what's what
why does the doctor need that little
office for anyway
you know his books little stupid
aquarium there
i guess he doesn't want people to see
him looking stuff up what the hell was
that
jesus christ
that was kind of gross
that wasn't the tube or the circle
a friend of mine is uh going in for a
nose job next week
guy
hostile you know what the technical term
for a nose job
well of course you do what's new york
everybody
rhinoplasty
rhino
now this guy is aware he has a bit of a
problem
he's obviously sensitive about it that's
why he made the appointment
do we need to compare him to a
rhinoceros
when you go for a hair transplant they
don't say we're going to perform a
cubolectomy on you mr johnson
we feel the chromedomia has advanced
to a level we term skinhedia
these are all medical terms that you
don't need to understand
there's another thing germs where did
the sudden fear of germs come from in
this country have you noticed this the
media constantly running stories about
all the latest infections salmonella e
coli hantavirus bird flu and and
americans are they panic easily so now
everybody's running around scrubbing
this and spraying that and overcooking
their food and repeatedly washing their
hands trying to avoid all contact with
germs it's ridiculous and it goes to
ridiculous lengths in prisons before
they give you a lethal injection they
swab your arm with alcohol
it's true
well
well they don't want you to get an
infection
and you can see their point wouldn't
want some guy to go to hell and be sick
it would take a lot of the sportsmanship
out of the whole execution
fear it germs why these [__] [__]
you can't even get a decent hamburger
anymore they cook the [__] out of
everything now because everybody's
afraid of food poisoning hey where's
your sense of adventure take a [__]
chance will you you know how many people
die in this country from food poisoning
every year 9 000 that's all it's a minor
risk
take a [__] chance bunch of goddamn
[__]
besides what do you think you have an
immune system for it's for killing germs
but it needs practice it needs germs to
practice on
so
so listen
if you kill all the germs around you and
live a completely sterile life then when
germs do come along you're not going to
be prepared and never mind ordinary
germs what are you going to do when some
super virus comes along that turns your
vital organs into liquid [__]
i'll tell you what you're gonna do
you're gonna get sick you're gonna die
and you're gonna deserve it because
you're [__] weak and you got a
[__] weak immune
system hey
hi
let me tell you a true story about
immunization okay when i was a little
boy in new york city in the 1940s we
swam in the hudson river and it was
filled with raw sewage okay
we swam in raw sewage you know to cool
off
and at that time the big fear was polio
thousands of kids died from polio every
year but you know something in my
neighborhood no one ever got polio no
one ever you know why because we swam in
raw sewage
it strengthened our immune systems the
polio never had a prayer we were
tempered in raw [__]
so
so personally i never take any special
precautions against germs i don't shy
away from people who sneeze and cough i
don't wipe off the telephone i don't
cover the toilet seat and if i drop food
on the floor i pick it up and eat it
i eat it
yes i do
[Applause]
even if i'm at a sidewalk cafe
in calcutta
the poor section
on new year's morning during a soccer
riot
and you know something in spite of all
that so-called risky behavior i never
get infections i don't get them i don't
get colds i don't get flu i don't get
headaches i don't get upset stomachs and
you know why because i got a good strong
immune system and it gets a lot of
practice my immune system is equipped
with the biological equivalent of fully
automatic military assault rifles with
night vision and laser scopes
and we have recently acquired phosphorus
grenades cluster bombs and
anti-personnel fragmentation mines
so when my white blood cells are on
patrol recon ordering my bloodstream
seeking out strangers and other
undesirables if they see any any
suspicious looking germs of any kind
they don't [__] around
they whip out the weapons they wax the
[__] and deposit the unlucky
fellow directly into my colon
into my colon there's no nonsense
there's no miranda warning there's none
of that three strikes and you're out
[__]
first defense bam into the colon you go
[Applause]
and speaking of my colon
i want you to know i don't automatically
wash my hands every time i go to the
bathroom okay can you deal with that
sometimes i do sometimes i don't you
know when i wash my hands when i [__] on
them
that's the only time
that's the oh and you know how often
that happens tops tops two three times a
week times
maybe a little more frequently over the
holidays you know what i mean
and i'll tell you something else my
well-scrubbed friends
you don't always need a shower every day
did you know that it's overkill unless
you work out or work outdoors or for
some reason come in intimate contact
with huge amounts of filth and garbage
every day you don't always need a shower
all you really need to do is to wash the
four key areas
armpits [__] crotch and teeth
got that armpits [__] crotch and
teeth
in fact you can save yourself a whole
lot of time if you simply use the same
brush on all four areas
[Applause]